avant que la vidéo du jour ne démarre je
vous invite à cliquer ici dans le petit
vous serez redirigé vers une émission à
laquelle j'ai pu participer avec la
chaîne déclic qui est une chaîne du
groupe Peugeot on a joué un quiz sur les
innovations les innovations dans
l'histoire c'était super j'ai fait
équipe avec Jigmé pour ceux qui
connaissent il y avait d'autres
créateurs de contenu vraiment je vous
invite à aller suivre ce quiz en plus il
y a un lot à gagner pour pour l'un
d'entre vous donc tentez votre chance et
voilà c'est ici dans le petit et
également dans la barre d'infos je vous
remercie et on enchaîne avec la vidéo du
jour
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous je suis ravie
de vous retrouver une nouvelle fois en
face caméra je commence dès l'intro
comme ça on sera tranquille à la fin de
la vidéo mais sachez que c'est très
important pour la chaîne que les vidéos
soient partagées soit liker c'est
vraiment une manière de soutenir mon
travail et celle de mon équipe et puis
si vous le pouvez bien entendu n'hésitez
pas à soutenir financièrement passer
sauvage je vous mets ici les liens dans
le petit
depuis que j'ai eu la chance d'approcher
la tombe de la dame de Vix son
gigantesques vases de bronze et son
fabuleux torque d'or pour un
documentaire avec National Geographic
j'avais envie de faire une vidéo sur les
femmes Celtes de l'âge du fer car cette
fabuleuse sépulture féminine n'est pas
un cas isolé à cette époque
protohistorique dans une grande région
au nord des Alpes on voit apparaître des
tombes de femmes extraordinaires
enterrées avec des richesses
considérables parfois avec des armes et
des chars des attributs qu'on imagine
plutôt masculin en temps normal celle
qu'on nomme souvent les princesses
Celtes ont intrigué des générations
d'archéologues elle pose en fait la
question du genre en archéologie c'est
un thème qu'on a déjà évoqué dans
plusieurs vidéos de la chaîne celles sur
l'anthropologue Margareth mit dans les
années 30 celle sur le prétendu
matriarcat primitif celle sur la place
des femmes en Grèce antique celle qui
présente l'oeuvre de Michel Perrault et
on en a aussi parlé dans la dernière
vidéo qui parle de Françoise Héritier et
ouais en fait on en parle très souvent
ici mais c'est normal c'est l'une des
grandes question transversale qui
irrigue les sciences humaines depuis les
années 70 et qui est sans doute l'une
des plus fécondes pour repenser les
sociétés du passé d'ailleurs quand
l'archéologie s'en empare vous allez
voir ça ouvre des perspectives
inattendues il faut dire aussi qu'il y
avait de quoi faire il suffit de voir
comment on a représenté les humains de
la préhistoire jusqu'à il y a pas si
longtemps qui chassait les hommes qui
fabriquaient les outils les hommes qui
peignaient au fond des cavernes les
hommes il y avait comme un problème
l'exemple qu'on va développer
aujourd'hui celui des princesses Celtes
nous permet d'entrevoir une autre
réalité et de questionner la manière
dont on perçoit le sexe ou le genre des
individus avec des vestiges
archéologiques
[Musique]
avant de commencer il faut préciser que
lorsqu'on va parler des Celtes ici on ne
parle pas de l'Irlande ou de la Bretagne
du Moyen-Âge c'est vrai que ce terme
recouvre une chronologie et une
géographie très étendue mais nous on va
oublier les triskells l'hydromel et les
clips de Nolwenn on va se concentrer sur
une période ancienne celle du début de
l'âge du Fer en fait cette période est
la première où l'on peut affirmer avec
certitude le caractère celte d'une
population grâce au texte grec et latin
qui mentionne leur contact avec ses
régions de l'intérieur du continent bien
sûr les Celtes ne sont pas apparues d'un
seul coup à ce moment-là et il existe
une continuité avec les périodes plus
anciennes de l'âge du bronze mais en
l'absence de traces écrite la langue et
l'appartenance ethnique sont impossibles
à définir cette époque des princesses
Celtes c'est donc celle de l'âge du fer
et de sa première subdivision qu'on
nomme la culture de Hallstatt du nom
d'un site archéologique d'Autriche cette
culture se développe au nord des Alpes
entre 800 et 450 avant Jésus-Christ
environ c'est l'époque du début de la
métallurgie du fer en Europe centrale
qui entraîne de profondes mutations dans
les sociétés des premières villes
fortifiées à apparaissent et les chefs
sont enterrés dans de riches tombes
couvertes par des tumulus à partir du
sixième siècle entre 600 et 500 avant
Jésus-Christ on observe un déplacement
des centres de pouvoir vers l'ouest vers
la vallée du Rhin de la Seine et de la
Saône et c'est peut-être à mettre en
relation avec la fondation de Marseille
par les Grecs vers 600 avant
Jésus-Christ et l'apparition de nouveaux
circuits commerciaux à destination de la
Méditerranée car le monde celtique était
en fait un intermédiaire commercial
privilégié profitant de sa position
centrale en Europe il a fait le relais
entre les îles britanniques la Baltique
et la Méditerranée les Grecs et les
Étrusques cherchant à se fournir en
nombre ou en étain entretenez donc des
échanges fréquents avec l'aristocratie
celtique qui s'enrichissait grâce au
commerce lingot d'étain contre aenfort
de vin perle d'ambre contre céramique
peinte les marchands parcourraient le
continent dans tous les sens 2500 ans
avant Schengen ou le marché commun c'est
dans ce contexte qu'apparaissent pour la
première fois des sépultures de femmes
totalement hors du commun mais avant
d'en faire une description il reste une
question à poser c'est quoi une
sépulture de femmes
[Musique]
la réponse semble assez évidente une
tombe de femme ben c'est une tombe avec
une femme dedans jusque là pas de
problème sauf qu'en archéologie les
choses ne sont pas toujours aussi
simples pour déterminer le sexe d'un
squelette on s'attarde normalement sur
des détails anatomiques qui montrent à
un dimorphisme sexuel c'est-à-dire une
différence de forme selon le sexe des
individus le plus simple pour les
spécialistes si on veut éviter de faire
des tests ADN qui coûte très très cher
c'est d'observer les os du bassin qui
sont clairement différenciées entre les
hommes et les femmes mais parfois ben on
les a pas ces eaux parfois l'acidité du
sol a rongé les ossements et tout le
squelette a carrément disparu parfois
les techniques de foues anciennes se
sont concentrées sur les et on négligé
d'étudier les restes osseux qu'on a
depuis perdu en bref on ne sait pas
toujours si le défunt était un homme ou
une femme c'est là qu'on peut
s'intéresser au matériel funéraire
depuis des millénaires les humains ont
en effet déposé des objets aux côtés de
leur mort surtout ceux qui appartenaient
à l'élite et ce matériel funéraire est
souvent jeanré on dépose pas la même
chose auprès d'un homme ou d'une femme
le principe est assez intuitif et les
archéologues ont depuis longtemps pensé
que les tombes dans lesquelles ont
retrouvé des épées et tes celles
d'hommes tandis que celle dans
lesquelles il y avait des bijoux étaient
des tombes de femmes et dans l'immense
majorité des cas c'est vrai mais bien
sûr il y a des contre-exemples qui
brûlent les pistes celles qui a été le
plus loin pour démêler tout ça et
analyser le genre dans les sépultures et
Caroline tremaux qui a justement fait sa
thèse sur la période qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui on y vient en analysant plus
de 721 tombent ostentatoires c'est à
dire avec du matériel riche répartis
entre la France l'Allemagne la Suisse
l'Autriche et la République
elle est parvenue à déterminer des
critères pour gérer les objets déposés
dans les sépultures un tel corpus qui
est le fruit du travail de centaines
d'archéologues depuis plus d'un siècle
permet de mener des études statistiques
et de dégager des tendances générales et
des évolutions bien marquées à l'échelle
de toute une civilisation c'est donc un
travail solide en résumé pour la période
qui nous intéresse les objets féminins
sont plutôt les anneaux de cheville les
pertes de bracelets les couteaux les
perles les bagues et les fusaïolles
tandis que les objets masculins sont les
arcs les poignards les lances les haches
les épées les casques les pierres à
aiguiser et les outils en tout genre
entre ces deux pôles gravitent des
objets neutres qui se retrouvent dans
les tons féminines et masculines tels
que les torques les instruments de
toilette la vaisselle métallique les
éléments de harnachement les chars les
brassards et les boucles d'oreilles ces
objets là ne renseignent pas sur le
genre de l'individu cela ne veut pas
dire que l'individu
lui même pas jeanrée de son vivant bien
sûr juste que le matériel qu'on lui a
attribué à sa mort ne le reflète pas
c'est comme si on déposait un smartphone
dans un cercueil tout le monde en a un
donc ça aide pas sur ces 721 sépultures
seul 8% des squelettes avaient pu être
déterminé anatomiquement comme homme ou
femme mais grâce à cette étude
minutieuse du matériel qui les
accompagnaient très mot a pu déterminer
le genre des défunts à 96%. cela donne
24% de tonde féminine 52% de tombe
masculine 20% de tombes neutre ou mixtes
et 4% d'indéterminés le neutre ou mixte
correspond ici au matériel non j'enré
vous avez compris
[Musique]
revenons à nos princesses seulement 24%
de sépulture féminine ça fait pas
beaucoup mais faut pas oublier qu'on
parle ici de tombes aristocratiques et
que les fonctions politiques et
guerrières étaient monopolisées par les
hommes dans toutes les sociétés
anciennes donc 24 % après tout c'est
peut-être pas si mal surtout quand on a
regardant de plus près les sépultures
féminines sont les plus riches grâce aux
calculs d'un indice de richesse qui
tient compte du nombre d'objets du poids
de métal et de leurs caractères
exotiques Caroline tremo a pu montrer
que les tombes de femmes possédaient le
matériel le plus riche je vous propose
donc de passer en revue quelques unes de
ces sépultures avant d'essayer de
comprendre qu'elle a pu être le rôle de
ces femmes extraordinaires dans la
société celte la plus célèbre est bien
entendu la tombe de Vix dont j'ai parlé
en introduction découverte en 53 au pied
du mont la soie et au bord de la Seine
la tombe datée d'environ 500 avant
Jésus-Christ était à l'origine
recouverte par un grand tumulus à raser
dans l'Antiquité à de la chambre
funéraire de 3 mètres de côté une femme
reposée sur un char avec des offrandes
exceptionnelles et parées de bijoux
merveilleux quand je dis offrant
d'exceptionnel c'est pas exagéré puisque
dans cette sépulture a été retrouvé le
plus grand vase en bronze de toute
l'antiquité fait d'une seule tôle de
bronze d'un millimètre d'épaisseur il
pèse 208 kg mesure un mètre 64 et peut
contenir presque 1200 litres de liquide
sa forme et son décor de style grec
illustre bien les contacts entre
l'aristocratie celtes et le monde
méditerranéen sur le col se déroule une
frise de soldats l'aisance portent des
effigies de gorgones entourés de Lyon et
de serpents le couvercle étant né d'une
statuette féminine les perles d'ambre et
les inclusions de corail dans les bijoux
montrent aussi ses contacts commerciaux
à longue distance vers la Baltique et la
Méditerranée enfin le torque avec ses
480 g d'or massif et aussi un
chef-d'œuvre d'orfèvrerie
les extrémités se terminent par des
boutons ornés de motifs géométriques et
de Pégase ailés c'est vraiment une
merveille même si le fouilleur de la
tombe René Geoffroy a tout de suite
reconnu des parures féminines dans la
tombe d'autres archéologues ont eu du
mal à accepter qu'il s'agit d'une
sépulture féminine le char l'absence
d'un époux inhumé avec elle la richesse
du dépôt tout suggère la plus haute
noblesse peut être même une forme de
pouvoir et difficile d'imaginer qu'une
femme ait pu atteindre un tel statut
social certains ont même émis l'idée
d'un prêtre déguisé en femme mais bon
depuis les eaux ont parlé c'est bien une
femme fouillez en 54 soit l'année après
vix la tombe princière de railhem est
situé à la frontière franco-allemande
tout près de Sarreguemines c'est une
tombe plus récente datée d'environ 370
avant Jésus-Christ qui illustre l'une
des dernières phases de ces riches
sépultures féminines dans une grande
chambre funéraire faite de planches de
chêne une femme reposait avec un très
riche mobilier un torque en or torsadé
des bracelets et boucles en or un miroir
en bronze et de la vaisselle métallique
de grande qualité l'acidité du sol a
fait totalement disparaître les
ossements mais le mobilier permet
clairement d'identifier une tombe
féminine tout indique encore une fois un
statut extrêmement élevé les perles en
verre et en nombre matière exotiques et
très précieuse permettent de
reconstituer une grande parure l'élément
le plus remarquable et sans doute la
cruche en bronze ouvrages surmonté d'un
cheval à tête humaine avec ses 50 cm de
hauteur c'est l'une des plus grandes
connues dans le monde celte les analyses
chimiques ont montré qu'elle était
remplie de vin quand elle a été déposée
dans la tombe aux côtés de la descente
était aussi présent un bâtonnet sculpté
en nombre avec des chaînettes en argent
les fouilleurs l'interprète comme un
élément cultuel faisant peut-être de sa
propriétaire une femme impliquée dans le
culte prêtresse ou prophétesse cette
hypothèse est renforcée par la
trouvaille de nombreux petits objets
interprétés comme des amulettes des
curiosités telles qu'une pointe de
flèches néolithique en silex des billes
de jaspe un petit bloc d'hématite ou
encore un fossile d'ammonites à
bettelbull dans le sud de l'Allemagne
une grande tombe féminine a été fouillée
bien plus récemment entre 2010 et 2011
la tombe a été trouvée à proximité de la
humburg qui est l'une des plus
importantes agglomérations Celtes de
l'âge du Fer et qui a livré de très
nombreux tertres funéraires les liens
avec le monde méditerranéen à paraissent
clairement par les vestiges d'un rempart
de terre crue un matériau inhabituel
dans ses latitudes on suppose donc que
des artisans Grecs spécialisés auraient
pu participer à la construction de la
ville la particularité de la fouille qui
nous intéresse c'est que les
archéologues ont fait le choix de
prélever toute la sépulture de la femme
en bloc un énorme bloc de 42 mètres
cubes pesant près de 80 tonnes a été
transporté en laboratoire pour être
fouillé dans des conditions optimales la
présence d'une abdos persistante a par
ailleurs conservé de nombreux restes
organiques en particulier la structure
en bois de la sépulture grâce à la
dendrochronologie l'analyse des cernes
de croissance des arbres les
archéologues ont pu dater le site avec
une précision extrême l'inhumation date
de 583 avant Jésus-Christ c'est une
information capitale parce que c'est
très rare de pouvoir poser des jalons
aussi précis dans la chronologie de
l'âge du Fer la tombe contient deux
individus l'inhumation principale au
centre de la chambre funéraire est une
femme
âgée entre 30 et 40 ans deux fibules
d'or ont été déposés près de ses épaules
et 4 fibules de bronze décorées d'ambre
sur sa poitrine il y avait aussi des
perles d'or et d'Ambres qui formaient un
collier de nombreux anneaux et bracelets
dont 7 en jets ainsi qu'une boucle en
dents de sanglier avec des pendant en
bronze et des objets en bois il n'y a
pas de torque en or comme à Vicks ou à
rynheim on n'en connaît pas en fait dans
les tombes féminines sitôt au sixième
siècle à côté de la défunte une tombe
d'enfants probable également une fille a
aussi fourni des fibules et dépendants
en or pas très loin de ce site le
tumulus de oh Michel
omiquéleux je ne sais pas comment ça se
prononce un tertre de 80 mètres de
diamètre et de 13 mètres de haut soit le
plus grand tumulus de l'âge du Fer a
aussi livré des informations importantes
pour nous fouiller il y a bien plus
longtemps il a révélé plusieurs
sépultures de couple mixtes datant du
sixième siècle avant JC dans l'une
d'entre elles qui n'avait pas été pillée
l'homme reposait sur le sol était vêtue
assez modestement et possédait quelques
armes mais la femme en revanche était
déposée sur un char et très richement
doté en perles d'ambre de verre ou de
corail des matières très précieuses et
exotiques une inégalité assez frappante
dans le tumulus du Grand communal dans
le Doubs la tombe principale était celle
d'une femme portant des anneaux de
jambes et des pendentifs en bronze deux
autres femmes aussi dotées de parures on
part la suite été inhumée auprès d'elle
ce qui pourrait indiquer une succession
générationnelle une sorte de de grandes
femmes pas très loin en Haute-Saône dans
le tertre de courtejoux et gâtés si
sépultures datées du début du sixième
siècle sont destinés à des femmes et à
une petite fille les sépultures
masculines n'apparaissent que plus tard
sur le site et sont bien moins richement
dotés voilà pour ce rapide aperçu il y a
beaucoup d'autres sépultures féminines
ostentatoires et on pourrait continuer à
un moment à les égrainer mais je pense
que vous avez compris l'idée il se passe
quelque chose avec les sépultures
féminines à cette époque
[Musique]
il y a plusieurs hypothèses pour
expliquer cette préminence des femmes
Celtes au début de l'âge du Fer certains
archéologues ont supposé que par manque
d'hommes dans l'élite à cette époque
certaines femmes auraient exercé des
rôles masculins devenant en quelque
sorte des malhonnorifiques reste à
savoir pourquoi tout à coup les mecs qui
auraient foutu le camp bon il y a aussi
l'hypothèse de femmes avec un rôle
religieux important comme certains
objets peuvent le faire penser mais les
indices sont souvent assez maigres un
miroir qui aurait pu servir à la
divination quelques amulettes d'autres
ont imaginé que les femmes auraient
simplement été des vecteurs d'alliance
entre les hommes des genres de femmes
trophées qui marquaient le statut social
des aristocrates mais franchement la
richesse des tombes féminines
supérieures à celle des hommes rend
difficile de les imaginer comme des
éléments passifs dans ces échanges une
idée peut être plus plausible et celle
avancée par Pierre-Yves Milcent
notamment d'une société matrilinaire à
cette époque une société matrilinéaire
je vous l'ai déjà expliqué ici c'est une
société dans laquelle les liens de
filiation se transmettent par la mer et
non par le père et c'est quelque chose
d'assez courant dans le monde selon
cette logique les dessins honorées
seraient ainsi des chefs de lignages des
ancêtres prestigieuses auxquels se
rattachait la communauté cela
expliquerait pourquoi de nouvelles
tombes étaient creusées à la périphérie
de leur tumulus dans les décennies
suivantes les personnes inhumées
prennent ces grandes femmes étaient
peut-être les membres de leur famille
élargi pour étayer son hypothèse
pas d'un simple ancêtre alors pourquoi
ne pas imaginer cela pour des femmes
pourquoi ne serait-elle pas aussi des
matriarches
parce que le matriarcat ça n'existe pas
certaines femmes peuvent accéder à des
statues élevés dans certains cas mais
partout dans le temps comme dans
l'espace les femmes ont une place
inférieure à celle des hommes
l'anthropologue Françoise Héritier a
appelé ça là Valence différentielle des
sexes on en a parlé dans la dernière
vidéo et c'est un invariant
anthropologique au même titre que
l'interdit de l'inceste l'intention
personne ne dit que l'inégalité c'est
très bien comme ça au contraire bref
allez voir cette vidéo précédente je la
mets là dans le petit lit c'est pas déjà
fait mais donc sachant que les femmes
n'ont jamais eu le pouvoir pourquoi ce
serait différent pour les Celtes de
l'âge du Fer ce serait la seule société
à avoir rompu ce principe universel mais
d'un autre côté pourquoi une sépulture
féminine devrait être interprétée
différemment une sépulture masculine
pourquoi quand on trouve un homme avec
de riches objets comme celui de Hoche
d'orf ou celui de Lavaux fouillé par
l'INRA en 2014 on affirme que ce devrait
être un chef et quand on trouve une
femme avec des richesses comparables
voire supérieur on dit que ce serait une
simple femme trophée il subsiste donc
une contradiction et finalement un
paquet d'incertitudes et quand on ne
comprend pas la logique c'est soit qu'on
a pas assez de données archéologiques
pour réfléchir mais bon là avec des
centaines de ton des statistiques dans
tous les sens ça commence à être clair
soit qu'il y a peut-être des biais
cachés dans nos raisonnements il ne faut
pas oublier qu'on ne peut pas observer
la société celte mais seulement les
sépultures de sa classe dirigeante le
portrait est forcément déformé est-ce
que les tombes de femmes importantes
ailleurs sont invisibles parce qu'elles
n'ont pas droit de telles offrandes ou
bien est-ce que les objets féminins
Celtes nous paraissent riches et
important alors qu'il ne l'était pas
tant le problème est-il notre perception
du genre ou de la richesse en bref et
pour ne pas finir que sur des questions
sans réponse Caroline tremo propose une
dernière hypothèse pour expliquer cette
richesse féminine au début de l'âge du
Fer c'est celle à ses séduisante je dois
dire d'un rôle actif des femmes comme
entrepreneuse dans des réseaux de
commerces international en un mot elles
auraient été des business woman
protohistoriques tous ces produits
exotiques comme l'ambre l'étain le
cuivre les céramiques peintes ou les
vases ouvragés qui circulaient plus que
jamais à l'époque aurait pu être échangé
sous leur direction et elles en auraient
ainsi conserver la preuve jusque dans la
mort voilà ce qu'on peut dire des
fameuses princesses Celtes pas de
réponse définitive mais il y aurait
encore plein d'aspects à évoquer pour
cette période comme les quelques cas de
transgression de genre autrement dit des
hommes inhumés avec des objets
clairement féminins ou le contraire en
élargissant on pourrait aussi parler des
régions du monde où l'on connaît des
tombes de femmes guerrières comme la
Suède ou l'Arménie mais on se réservera
peut-être ça pour une prochaine fois
n'hésitez pas à regarder la
bibliographie en barre de description si
vous voulez en savoir plus plusieurs
articles sont disponibles gratuitement
en ligne et vous aurez des éléments
supplémentaires d'ailleurs merci à
Caroline tremo qui nous a gentiment
envoyé l'un de ses articles
qu'on n'arrivait pas à trouver sur
internet je vous remercie j'espère que
cette vidéo vous a plu n'hésitez pas à
la liker à la commenter à la partager
vous pouvez soutenir la chaîne ici je
vous dis à dans 15 jours pour un
prochain épisode de mission et d'ici là
vous pouvez me retrouver sur twitch tous
les mercredis à 19h on fait des parties
d'archéogeers c'est une version
archéologique de geogaisseur tous les
mercredis à 19h salut
[Musique]